as plenary sessions are the most
important moments in the European
Parliament's calendar over 30 hours of
debates discussions and votes take place
in the hemicycle in the space of four
days but it's far from all when not in
the chamber members go to one of a
hundred and sixty meetings that are
scheduled during the plenary to ensure
transparency details of these meetings
are listed on the European Parliament's
website it's 6:00 p.m. on Tuesday its
political groups time in the European
People's Party group MEP s are
exchanging ideas with a commissioner the
group has to decide which positions it
will defend on the latest reports at the
same time a debate on Syria is going on
in the planer in representing the
Socialists and Democrats this MEP is
also due to get back to his group
meeting each of the eight political
groups will get together at least once
during the week and for some groups this
could even mean as many as 50 meetings
in four days as their national
delegations meet separately the plenary
is also an occasion for some committees
to carry out urgent work and as during
votes attendance is checked members have
other obligations like talking of
diplomats and explaining policy
decisions to visitors
finally MEP s have to speak to the media
to keep everyone informed which all
makes for a very packed diary
the plenum chamber is only the visible
part of what MEP s do but their work
goes far beyond the walls of meeting
rooms in or out of the chamber the work
continues
[Music]